how are you Penelope you look stunning
tonight I'm good you too thank you oh
and happy belated birthday how did you
celebrate thank you so much with my
family in Madrid oh incredible my family
and friends I guess the celebration
honestly kind of continues here tonight
but yes this is a very emotional day
because we all
we were very lucky to be able to spend
time with Carl and I I love him and miss
him so much and to be here celebrating
him is really special and emotional
beautiful what are you married
Chanel is a Couture spring summer from
1988.
wow and you had the opportunity to walk
in Carl's final show just after his
death how was that an honor to you and
what will you always cherish about your
relationship with Carl that he was very
special he was
very kind to me I met him in 1999 and I
was always wearing his designs and and
then a few years before he died he asked
me to be an ambassador of the brand and
then we became very close friends and he
was a very special brilliant person that
is very missed
well what we're on your to-do list as a
co-chair for the for the Met Gala this
year what did Anna winter have you doing
we were able to get together yesterday
and
with Anna
Michaela and talk a little bit about
about the plants here tonight things
that I cannot tell you but thank you
a few surprises
[Music]